president biden has nominated judge
katanji brown jackson to the supreme
court
the first black woman nominated to be a
justice on the nation's highest court if
confirmed she would replace justice
stephen breyer a liberal member of the
court who announced his retirement in
january judge jackson served as a law
clerk to justice breyer earlier in her
career i've been a federal judge for
eight years
and i have a duty
of independence
i clerked for three federal judges
before i became a judge
and they were models
of
judicial independence
and what that has meant
is that i know very well what my
obligations are what my duties are
not to
rule
with partisan advantage in mind what
makes her a strong nominee in part is
that professional diversity
this sort of allows biden to fulfill a
promise that he's made to diversify the
court not just by putting people on the
court who might have a different
demographic background who might look
different but people who might also just
bring a different kind of experience
another thing that makes her a strong
nominee is that she was just recently
confirmed to the dc circuit and so it
means that she's gone through the senate
confirmation process the president made
his decision after meeting with the
candidates studying their histories and
case records and consulting legal
experts the white house said although we
have a pretty closely divided senate um
we think she still probably had a pretty
smooth path um to confirmation um uh
president vice president harris casts
the deciding vote um and give against
democrats the majority mr biden's
nomination won't change the balance of
power on a conservative high court that
has six justices appointed by republican
presidents including three by former
president donald trump
judge jackson currently serves on the
u.s court of appeals for the district of
columbia circuit one of the nation's
most influential courts and often a
stepping stone for supreme court
justices she joined the court last june
after spending eight years as a federal
trial judge in the nation's capital so
president biden has promised to
diversify the federal judiciary in terms
of both demographic background and
professional diversity um and judge
jackson ticks both of those boxes she'll
be the first black woman on the court um
and she also brings background
background as a criminal defender um
which we have not seen um in many many
years i would say
that
my different professional background
than many of the court of appeals judges
including my
district court background which will be
different if i'm confirmed than many of
my my colleagues
would bring value
it's sort of like the oliver wendell
holmes quote that the life of the law is
not logic it's experience
and so i've experienced life
uh in in perhaps a different way than
some of my colleagues because of who i
am
and that might
be valuable uh i hope it would be
valuable if i was confirmed to the court
republicans have tried to pin her down
on this question of the quote-unquote
living constitution the idea that
constitutional interpretation should
adapt the social change should evolve
over time
um she said in 2013 at her confirmation
at a confirmation hearing the district
court that she disagreed with that um
but more recently at her appeals court
confirmation hearing she really just
declined to talk about it and defer to
the supreme court the constitution is an
enduring document it is uh it has
the supreme court has said
a fixed meaning
that we're to look to the original
words in the constitution and
interpret
as lower court judges interpret
provisions the way in which the supreme
court does and they
look at the text and meaning judge
jackson has not said very much about
what kind of a presence she will be on
the court um as is common with lower
court judges we don't know very much
about her judicial philosophy
and when she was asked about it at a
recent confirmation hearing she really
declined to talk very much about it and
deferred to the supreme court i think
that i would like to be remembered as a
judge who was both careful
and thorough in my opinions it remains
unclear exactly when judge jackson's
confirmation hearings will begin but new
york senator chuck schumer said they
will take place in the coming weeks